the distance between points a and B is 8
kilometers Xen begins at Point a and
covers half this distance at 2 km/h half
the distance would be 4 kilometers and
from this point to B he travels at 4
km/h as the total distance is 8
kilometers and this is 4 kilometers this
distance will equal 4 kilometers so he
runs half the distance at 2 km/h and the
remaining half at 4 km/h what will be
his average speed yes we haven't seen
this concept of average speed earlier
pause the video and try to find this
average speed it's easy as he travels
half the distance at 2 kilometers per
hour and the remaining half at 4
kilometers per hour his average speed
will be 2 plus 4 over 2 this is the
average of the two numbers that will be
6 over 2 or 3 kilometers per hour that
Zen's
average speed over this distance and as
some of you might have guessed this is a
classic mistake that many students make
so what is the average speed there is
just one thing we need to understand
about average speed it equals the ratio
of the total distance traveled to the
total time taken to travel that distance
yes
total distance divided by the total time
so let's see what it will be in this
case the total distance traveled is 4
plus 4 or 8 kilometers and what is the
total time taken we haven't been given
the total time taken but can we find
that out the time taken is equal to the
distance divided by the speed and the
total time taken will equal the sum of
the times taken to travel each part the
time taken to travel the initial 4
kilometers will equal 4 over 2 and the
time taken to travel the second part
will equal 4 over 4 the sum equals the
total time taken by Xen to cover the
distance between points a and B the
numerator will equal 8 and the Deneuve
later we'll equal to +1 then takes 3
hours to travel from point A to point B
we get the average speed as 8 over 3
that's approximately two point six six
kilometers per hour wait a moment
look at the two speeds then traveled at
two and four kilometers per hour why is
the average speed closer to two why
isn't it closer to four here's the
answer the average speed is closer to
two kilometers per hour because then is
traveling for more time at that speed he
is traveling at two kilometers per hour
for two hours and at four kilometers per
hour for one hour if then would have
traveled for more time at four
kilometers per hour the average speed
would have been closer to four
kilometers per hour and not two
kilometers per hour now let's look at a
new example on a new page Zen travels at
two kilometers per hour for half hour
and then at four kilometers per hour for
two hours what will be his average speed
pause the video and give it a shot
we just learnt that the average speed
equals the total distance divided by the
total time taken to travel that distance
do we have the total distance no but we
can find that out yes it will be the sum
of these two distances the product of
speed and time gives us the distance two
multiplied by one half will give us this
distance and four times two will give us
this distance this sum gives us the
total distance and the total time will
equal the sum of these two time
durations one-half plus 2 this is one
plus eight which is nine and the
denominator will be 0.5 plus two which
is two point five let's zoom out and
write the answer we get nine over two
point five to solve this we can multiply
the numerator and the denominator by 4
we get 36 over 10 which equals three
point six kilometers per hour this as we
can see is closer to four kilometers per
hour
it's
closer to 4 km/h because he's travelling
for more time at that speed let's look
at one last problem to understand
average speed Zen travels at 3 km/h for
6 kilometres and 5 km/h for 10
kilometers what will be his average
speed pause the video and solve this one
the average speed is the ratio of the
total distance to the total time taken
to travel that distance the total
distance will be 6 plus 10 what will be
the total time it will be the sum of the
time durations for each of these parts
the time taken to cover this part will
equal 6 over 3 or 2 hours and the time
taken to travel this part will equal 10
over 5 or 2 hours so the total time will
equal 2 plus 2 or 4 hours that will
equal 16 over 4 4 km/h is this closer to
3 or to 5 it's equidistant from each and
why is that it's because he is traveling
for the same time at each of the speeds
hence this is the average of the
individual speed rates we will look at
more examples of average speed over the
next few sessions